welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and this is a breakdown of moon 9
episode 3 that made my mind meltmate
like oh my days oh my moon gods what is
going on like guys are you seeing what
i'm seeing right now do you know the
possible ramifications that the events
of this episode could mean for the
future of the mcu guys the entire planet
went back in time two thousand years i'm
sorry my voice is like this but this is
a big deal all right i'm gonna get into
what this huge event could mean for the
mcu a little bit later but for now let
us get into all the juicy hidden details
that you missed from this visually
incredible entry in steve grant's wild
mind-bending mystery and hey before i
continue make sure to hit up
newrockstarsmerch.com
so you can find all of our new cool moon
night hoodies and shirts and all of our
cool moon night stuff are there just
head on over to rockstars.com so that
you can look cool and wear some cool
shirts like this and remember that this
latest obsession shirt is not going to
last forever so pick it up immediately
because it's going to sell out all right
i love how right off the bat the episode
starts us off with a cut from black that
starts off blurry but gets more clear
revealing layla having her pictures
taken for fake illegal ids like what a
great cinematography choice by series
director mohamed diap in series director
of photography gregory middleton because
it feels like the audience is waking up
from that blackness to an unfocused
blurriness like eyes first waking up and
then revealing layla in focus very much
intentionally reflecting the overall
theme of mark spector and steven grant
constantly waking up from blackouts a
little bit disoriented themselves and
the fact that we begin outside of mark
or steven's point of view which is rare
for the series tells us that there is
some legitimacy to his experience or
that layla might also be experiencing
the delusion and then we get a look at
layla's fake passport to the arab
republic of egypt with the information
being edited on a computer screen by a
close family forger friend of leyla's
stating that leila's full name is
actually leila abdullah el
and that she was actually an egyptian
born in cairo on october 28 1994 on a
day when the moon was actually in its
waning crescent phase i might add which
is quite interesting considering layla's
personal choice of murder jewelry in the
form of a shoulder stabbing
crescent-shaped necklace which might
just hint at a possible family
connection with the moon god conchu
himself as that necklace could be a
family heirloom of sorts i mean her
middle name abdallah does mean flower of
the god after all so maybe that's a clue
there and then we learn that this fake
passport has an issue date of may 29th
2019 which heavily implies that layla
herself was not snatched by thanos and
infinity war which is also the same case
for mark specter as we see from an
earlier episode's passport as well
though we can't 100 take this as a
reliable source since this is a fake id
after all being faked again by a close
family friend of the alpha hulys played
by barbara rosenblatt who is no stranger
to comic book tv shows as she recently
appeared on the tv show gotham as lydia
bishiri the bar owner of lydia's bar and
guys while mark spector is exploring the
sands of egypt you can explore millions
of champion combinations and master
countless tactics in a game that is
taking over mobile gaming raid shadow
legends use the links below to download
raid to your mobile phone or pc let's
talk about a few of my favorite
champions in the game because we got the
royal guard in the royal guard is one of
the heaviest hitters in all of raid his
damage scales on enemy hp so he's a huge
nuker against bosses and cardio is a
great champion for the arena he boosts
the damage dealing of the rest of your
team and protects them from dying which
is clutch and he also looks like a cool
battle angel which i really dig and this
year is raid's three-year anniversary
and they've introduced new champion
skins so that you can alter your look of
your favorite champions and they've got
a lot of big events coming up so stay
tuned for that and this is the best time
to get started in raid and if you click
my link in the description box below or
scan my qr code here on the screen
you'll get a free starter pack worth
almost 40 dollars like we're talking
three champions at once we got
misericord we got tiger scout and we got
romero plus 100 magic xp brews 10 force
xp brews and 100 spirit brews that's a
lot of brews that's huge and all of this
treasure will be waiting for you here
and it's that easy just click the link
in the description and i'll see you in
the game and while layla is talking to
this forging family friend she reveals
to her that her and mark spector once
had a place together not 20 minutes away
from steven's current apartment where
nemo ii is almost assuredly floating at
the top of that tank because he has not
gotten food for a very long time which
could be a reason why mark spector could
have chosen this location to hide out in
the first place as steven grant probably
to remind him of the love that he's been
forced to leave behind as this new fist
of konchu and layla also reveals that
it's been 10 years since her last visit
to her homeland of cairo which is
curious to me considering that she does
note later on in the episode that her
name isn't the most popular around those
parts you should be here why because my
name pisses off a few people in cairo so
i'm very curious to learn what exactly
happened within her family's history to
cause all the locals to be giving a
family of archaeologists the side eye i
mean she had to be gone for 10 years for
a reason after all but it might just
have to do with layla's current
profession as a type of ancient artifact
robin hood figure that steals from the
anti-collecting underground to return
those various valuable pieces of history
back to their respective cultures as she
believes all of these artifacts to be
stolen a completely not wrong belief
also shared by a former anti-collector
eric killmonger during his totally
normal field trip to a museum that
wasn't at all a robbery and because we
know that she deals with black market
antiques this might just mean that she
knows the power broker from falcon aware
soldier who we already know loves
antiques and all like paintings and all
that stuff so i do expect sharon carter
to pop up at some point this season
especially since the pirate country
madrapore is literally name dropped a
little bit later in the episode after my
repo i'm sure you two will have a lot to
talk about then the two ladies reminisce
about laila's late father who was an
archaeologist that apparently brought
his daughter along on all of his digs
possibly alluding to the dead
archaeologists hinted at in the last
episode this of course sounding
extremely similar to the circumstances
of comic mark spectre's love interest
marlene allaron whose father was gunned
down by a crazy mercenary named bushman
during mark's origin story in the comics
but we also learned from this forgery
lady that layla's father liked to call
layla his little scarab possibly linking
layla and her family to the series
mcguffin the golden scarab leading to
the greatest treasure of all robin
williams in the cave of wonders
just kidding that's another disney-owned
franchise i mean the tomb of vomit like
maybe layla was always meant to be
amit's true avatar who knows and then we
get the marvel studios logo coming in
set to some really dope middle eastern
trap music by dj kaboo called enta which
is actually a bop and a dope way to hint
at the faithful portrayal of a modern
day cairo that moon knight director
mohammad diab was extremely keen on
delivering even going as far as calling
egypt's depiction in hollywood media
like you know wonder woman 1984
disgraceful his words not mine i haven't
even seen wonder woman 1984 so i can't
even hate on that movie
and you know what after watching how
beautifully indifferently this episode
of moon knight captures the vibrant
excitement of a 21st century cairo in a
way that i've never seen before
personally this director might just know
what he's talking about because cairo
looks dope as hell in the show but
anyways when we first meet arthur
harrell following the golden compass to
his favorite crocodile queen i could not
help but get the image of moses guiding
his own people through the deserts of
egypt in the judaic scriptures with the
figure of moses often being drawn as a
prominent figure in red much like arthur
harrell seems to be the only person
wearing red amongst this group in the
desert feel like there's a very
intentional design choice and when we
first meet mark this episode he's doing
exactly what layla thought he was doing
and trying not to get himself killed
running around cairo he's probably going
to get himself killed running around
cairo
and when mark gets into a fight with
some dramatic knife fighting guys with
the lead one even tossing a knife up to
the camera like some sort of cool guy
giving us a slow-mo zooming of that
knife throw that reminds me of the wasp
dodging knives in the kitchen in ant-man
and the wasp but then we get some really
dope knife combat back in the mcu since
the amazingness that was that winter
soldier knife fight from many moons ago
with that alpha thug taking the lead
being the actor jaleel nassiri who is
showing us some of that amazing knife
skill that made liam neeson sweat during
that final battle in the first taken
movie
[Music]
and then we see mark even pulling a
punch before choosing to slap this young
thug over here which sort of calls back
to his other personality's conversation
with arthur harrow's last episode when
he brings up his blatant objection to
hurting children what about a child
would she kill a child for something
they might do in 30 years i kind of draw
a line there at child murder so even
though these two are separate
personalities it seems like they have
very similar values take him to the
ledge he's just a kid and after mark
blacks out in the middle of that roof
fight we get our first look at waking up
from a personality switch from mark's
perspective as steve tries to book it
out of egypt in a cab which you know i
don't i don't blame him he's like all
right i'm in another country again time
to go home
i hope i was just nonchalant about like
i did it again
and i thought it was absolutely
hilarious when we get the cab driver a
little later yelling where's my money to
moon knight as it felt like it could
have been like a slight nod to the
famous moon knight meme of mark spektor
yelling i know you're here dracula you
big nerd where's my goddamn money and
then one of the biggest what the moments
of the show happens when mark actually
catches up with those culti roof thugs
on the street and gets bumped on the
head twice once by a thug with a blunt
object and once again after his head
lands hard on the ground which seems to
cause him to wake up from the actions of
an entity that is neither mark or
stephen a version of mark who seemingly
didn't care about getting the
information mark needed out of these
people he just killed them literally
everyone but this young boy gets gutted
by this mysterious new personality a
personality that i hope and believe to
be that of jake lockley the street smart
new york cab driver who has up until
this point been largely absent in the
series and with moon knight's mirror
cinematography seemingly hinting at
three personalities hidden inside this
one marked body this actually made up
ending being the case as that would be
extremely comic book accurate and of
course before this young boy cuts his
red scarf to meet the base ahmet in the
sky he says praise it much like the
agents of mcu's first main cults hydra
would yell hail hydra before they
committed suicide
and then went directly to hell because
they were nazis but hey speaking of this
boy scarf a really interesting design
detail that i've been noticing with the
moon knight series is that a lot of mark
and steven's enemies seem to be adorned
in this particular shade of red you know
this boy's scarf and air the cops that
stopped by steven's house the goons that
shot at steven in germany and also
arthur harrow himself hell even midnight
man was wearing red particularly a shade
of red similar to that of the scarlet
witch and her chaos magic which arthur
has hinted could be playing a factor
between both him and mark so all of his
servants choosing this shade could be
indicative of some chaos magic influence
in the series but anyways konchu finally
gives us some details about how
moonite's healing armor is able to give
him a healing factor that rivals
wolverine with both mark and steve
proving this by taking several poles to
the torso without passing away during
their battle at moguards a battle that
reminded me so much of peter quill in
avengers infinity war when steve grant
calls time out and tells everyone to
chill the f out we're all worked up it's
all just like chill the f out everybody
stay where you are chill the f out but
anyways when mark and consho have their
conversation on the cliffside concho
reveals the one thing in the universe
that he fears the wrath of the council
of gods which kanchu later has to face
through this avatar inside the great
pyramid of giza one of the seven wonders
of the world which secretly doubles as a
council room for the pantheon of
egyptian gods as nine seats for each god
avatar can be seen though only five of
the nine isis tefnut osiris hathor and
horus show up for conscious trial after
he literally moved the moon to make an
eclipse to make this meeting even
possible and yaziel avatar to the
goddess of music and love hathor played
by native american actress diana
bermudez also hints at a hidden
potentially romantic past between hathor
and kanchu when she says she says it was
not so long ago konchu enjoyed hathor's
melodies as far as i know the only
melody kanchu enjoys is the sound of
pain which does make sense considering
that konchu and hathor have had a
romantic past in egyptian mythology and
considering that konchu is the god of
the moon and hathor is also in addition
to music and love the goddess of the sky
these two were a match made in heaven
literally made in the heavens of the sky
because you can't have the moon without
the sky but yeah guys i don't know about
you but i do not trust hathor at all
like zero percent not her avatar however
seems nice especially when this flash of
white colored light seems to appear over
harrow's head right before half lure
leaves the mind of vietnam check that
out slow it down i definitely feel like
the goddess hathor and hero are in
cahoots like you can't trust nobody with
an h in the front of their name in the
show okay i have this feeling that
because this goddess of love's love for
kanchu she could actually be the true
villain of this series trying to create
a heaven on earth so her and her
banished former lover konshu could live
together on and look at the stars
together forever because like i said
hathor is the goddess of the sky and the
sky and the moon are always meant to be
together no matter what which could be
why konchu says that he remembers every
night because he is remembering his love
for the sky or hathor but anyways when
the leader of the group horus says
you've been banished once for nearly
exposing us honshu and you know we
despise your garishness
your showy masks and weapons we learned
that not only do these gods really have
no love for conscie but they're also not
wants to have actively violent
flamboyant avatars with boon-themed
weapons running around the earth very
much implying that for now moon knight
is the only avatar of its kind though i
do suspect that arthur herrera will end
up becoming the shadow knight who is in
the comics and you know basically just
an evil movement and we also learn that
these gods have all abandoned mankind
because mankind has abandoned worship of
them with konchu claiming that all of
these gods are living in opulence in a
place called the overvoid better known
in the marvel comics as the celestial
heliopolis a pocket dimension outside
the main marvel universe where the inead
be ballin in paradise something that
both khanshu and four fours poor the
godbutcher share a problem with because
gore does not like that the gods do not
help mankind out at all but anyways when
mark and layla are on that purple tinted
boat ride catching up we get a tiny look
into mark's struggle with his mental
illness with him telling layla that he's
been struggling with it for a very long
time until something happened recently
to cause him to lose the control that
he's mastered over it over the years
with that something very likely being
his first meeting with konshu who
probably messed with his brain chemistry
and we finally get a look at gaspard
yuliel's anton mogart also known as
marvel's midnight man a villain in moon
knight's rogues gallery who love to
steal valuable things not for the money
but simply for the sake of having them
kinda like the collector from guardians
of the galaxy one and mogart earns the
title of midnight man in the comics
simply because of his preference to
strike at the dead of night at midnight
for all of his crimes which is why we
see kanchu saying tick-tock over a clock
that just struck midnight at the very
end of this incredible action sequence
and of course the late guest bard would
have a tribute from marvel at the very
end of this episode rest in peace buddy
and speaking of tick-tock on the clock
guys i'm not sure if you missed this but
it kind of seems like konshu in an
effort to you know return the stars to
the position that they were 2 000 years
in the past when senpu first marked the
tomb of ahmet thought that the only way
to do that was to change the sky itself
by turning back time which could be the
reason for the beautiful light show at
the episode's end it's literally the
stars in the sky going back in time and
how exactly can concho do this by
manipulating gravity something that the
moon is heavily associated with and
possibly why kanchu was able to
effortlessly cause an eclipse earlier on
in the episode by moving the moon and
guys if this is the case and the earth
has been sent 2 000 years into the
universe's past do you guys know what
this means this means that the infinity
stones are back asgard is back xandar is
back hella is back ego the living planet
is back the entire universe is just 2
000 years younger like guys in my
opinion this is potentially one of the
biggest things to happen to the mcu
since the snap mostly because we see
conscious turned to stone before he can
put this guy back where he found it like
man oh man can i not wait to see how
this could potentially change the entire
mcu game for phase four because this is
freaking nuts man freaking nuts and
finally we end the episode with the
revelation that not only did arthur
harrow truly enjoy herding in the name
of konchu but that kanchu was the very
reason why he chose this weird path of
healing because kanju was the one who
gave him a taste for blood and
destruction and he even goes as far as
to thank the imprisoned conscie for his
victory to come and man you know ethan
hawk can act when you forget that he's
straight up sassing a statue of a bird
for like 60 seconds
but anyways that is it for this
breakdown of moon knight episode three
what did you guys think of this episode
like do you guys think that i'm crazy
and the earth didn't actually go back in
time 2000 years because it looks like
that's what happened let us know what
you thought in the comment section below
my nerd babies because i want to hear it
i want to hear it but anyways thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow me at mastertainment on
twitter if you want to see me tweet some
really weird [ __ ] and really fun
theories more importantly you can follow
new rockstars wherever we are on social
media just make sure you hit that
notification bell on youtube so that you
can get notifications whenever we upload
a video which is basically every day and
also again please hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can find our
cool mooneye inspired merch because it
really helps the channel if you love new
rock stars and you want to support us
this is literally the best way to do it
so head off to new rockstarsmerch.com
today thank you guys so much for
watching this video i love you guys so
much and i appreciate you guys always
spending time with me seriously i love
you see you guys next time bye
[Music]
you